all animals experience fear human beings
perhaps
most of all the government depends on it
to secure popular submission
compliance with official dictates and on
some occasions
affirmative cooperation with the state's
enterprises and adventures
wrote the historian robert higgs in a
2005 essay
the storming of the capital was a
horrifying event and americans were
understandably traumatized
but the reaction to a crisis also
requires special vigilance
after the horror of the 9 11 attacks
americans
acquiesced in the face of any policy
that promised to keep them safe
we got mass surveillance deadly foreign
wars
state-sanctioned torture and the
incompetent department of homeland
security
this week's armed lockdown of dc in
preparation for the swearing-in of a new
government
provides us with a visceral feel for the
legislative proposals we can expect
in the months to come they were a
riotous
mob insurrectionist domestic
terrorist it's that basic it's that
simple
in his remarks after the capital attack
joe biden promised to revive
a domestic terrorism bill that would as
he put it
make the same commitment to root out
domestic terrorism
as we have made to stopping
international terrorism
this from a man who repeatedly claimed
authorship of the patriot act
which turned regular citizens into
suspects
in the words of the aclu congresswoman
alexandria ocasio-cortez
objected to the call for a new domestic
terrorism bill
noting that our problems on wednesday
weren't that there weren't enough laws
resources or intelligence we had them
and they were not used
she pointed to a different culprit we're
going to have to figure out
how we reign in our media environment
so that you can't just spew
disinformation
and misinformation it's one thing to
have differing opinions
but it's another thing entirely
to just say things that are false to let
government agencies
reign in the media is to put control
over speech
in the hands of people who always see
the benefit in less scrutiny and
criticism of their own actions
you never want a serious crisis to go to
waste
and what i mean by that it's an
opportunity to do things that you think
you could not do before
by keeping the population in a state of
artificially heightened apprehension
the government come media prepares the
ground for planting specific measures of
taxation
regulation surveillance reporting and
other invasions of the people's wealth
privacy and freedoms
wrote higgs a politician's wish list of
expanded powers
is endless we must be especially careful
when
fear overtakes us not to turn a blind
eye
to a different threat coming straight at
us